revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya con nosotros en el
estudio Marta ya estamos a miércoles
mitad de semana y vamos a empezar esta
revista de prensa en nuestra región
porque ayer la fiscalía de Perú acusó
constitucionalmente al presidente Pedro
castillo de liderar una presunta red
criminal dentro del gobierno digamos
también financiada con los fondos
públicos esto dice la fiscalía una
noticia que por supuesto impactado de
lleno toda la prensa local y comenzamos
con Perú 21 Buenos días Raúl Así es
feliz miércoles para ti también continúa
el caos en Perú empezamos como decías
con el Perú 21 que titula este miércoles
el gobierno de Pedro Castillo captó a
congresistas a cambio de favores
políticos sostiene que la fiscal
Patricia Benavides dice que impulsó esta
demanda constitucional contra Pedro
castillo y que él habría intentado
persuadir y que de hecho lo hizo a 37
congre para perpetuarse en el poder y
Seguir generando ganancias políticas
según los documentos de este periódico
nos referimos a 37 legisladores de
diferentes bancadas políticas recordemos
que ayer fueron detenidos cinco ex
asesores de Pedro castillo y se hallaron
la residencias y las oficinas de otros
seis
parlamentarios así como la casa de la
hermana de Pedro Castillo el presidente
dijo que todo esto era abusivo y como
decíamos en el informativo lo catálogo
como una nueva modalidad de golpe de
estado Bueno vamos con la República
Marta la República hace una editorial
que dice derecho constitucional en
debate tras la acusación de la fiscal se
abre un debate legal sobre si esta tiene
la capacidad para iniciar los trámites
de la denuncia constitucional apelando a
un tratado internacional de Naciones
Unidas contra la corrupción y además el
papel que juega el congreso en todo este
lío dice vectorial de la república que
es un momento decisivo para el país con
una saga de acciones delictivas por
parte del presidente e incluso su
círculo familiar y la apatía de un
congreso para enfrentar su
responsabilidad política seguimos con
este repaso de la prensa local con el
comercio sí Raúl el comercio también
publica un artículo de opinión que
titula castillo y los límites de su
inmunidad se refiere este artículo de
opinión a que la inmunidad es una norma
que tiene que dar estabilidad a la
presidencia y que Castillo está haciendo
todo lo contrario la teoría del derecho
constitucional sostiene este artículo
plantea una solución a esta a esta
problemática que se llama lagunas
axiológicas que se aplican cuando una
ley sobre un caso concreto no da
resultados o da Perdón resultados
incompatibles con los fundamentos del
ordenamiento jurídico por tanto dice
Esta debe ser la ruta a explorar por la
fiscalía y el con finalizamos este tema
con correo diario el correo diario
también señala una cita del jefe del
Consejo de ministros de Perú Aníbal
Torres que dice solicitaré a Naciones
Unidas una opinión dice que si la fiscal
Patricia benavides no tiene en cuenta el
código penal peruano o la Constitución
ese artículo 117 al que nos referíamos
en el informativo estaría vulnerando de
manera manifiesta la Carta Magna peruana
gracias a Marta por este primer bloque
seguimos en nuestro continente y nos
vamos hasta Haití donde continúan las
protestas por el pedido de ayuda
internacional que hizo el Primer
Ministro Ariel Henry una decisión que
desde la parte de la precio occidental
se ve con buenos ojos aunque con matices
Marta y al interno de la nación hay
medios que la catalogan como una nueva
invasión porque vamos con algeciras
recogemos primero al jazeera que habla
de las protestas que han tenido lugar
estos últimos días Raúl ayer dice que
los haitianos están contra el llamado
del gobierno a enviar fuerzas
extranjeras a su país recordemos que el
viernes Raúl el Primer Ministro hizo
esta solicitud de ayuda militar
internacional y que estaría liderada por
Estados Unidos y Canadá las personas se
manifiestan en contra de este pedido de
Ariel Henry diciendo que el Primer
Ministro no tiene la legitimidad para
hacer este pedido ya que está en
funciones porque no ha habido elecciones
en el país desde el magnicidio de
jovenel Moisés y además os tienen que
las fuerzas extranjeras no pueden
meterse en asuntos internos del país
además estas protestas han sido
altamente reprimidas ayer dejaron un
muerto al menos cómo lo ve el Washington
post El Washington post hace una
editorial que titula sí a la
intervención en Haití y un impulso a la
democracia ese sí no obstante tiene
matices porque sostiene que no puede ir
de la mano con un apoyo al actual
gobierno y Así que es necesario un claro
posicionamiento de la comunidad
internacional a esa intervención pero
que no suponga un mayor derramamiento de
sangre
hace un repaso por estas últimas
noticias y dice que aunque es
necesaria quizá una intervención
la sociedad haitiana sí o no va a tener
que recibir a las botas internacionales
en su territorio y que aunque puede que
algo cambie a corto o mediano plazo la
historia demuestra que la intervención
internacional en el país no ha dado
frutos a largo plazo Marta Moya gracias
por toda la información mañana con más
revista de prensa aquí en directo
América